that's kind of strange all right so last
time we were talking about circuit
analysis algorithms i surveyed a whole
bunch of different running times that
are known for
different kinds of analysis problems for
circuits
and now i'll talk more about the
circumplexity side of things today so
i'll try to go a bit slower
than just
just an overview of
a bunch of different bounds and some
ideas behind them i'll try to just give
you at least a
reminder crash course of circuit
complexity
and um
and also
get to connections between these two
in other words
when you're mixing blue and red we get
purple okay
so
all right let's get started
so the way we've been looking at
circuits is there are finite objects
that take a finite number of inputs and
output a bit
and it's
natural to ask like well can you use
circuits to compute infinite languages
okay like problems of the usual kind
that are solved via algorithms or turing
machines
and so this is done in the following way
we allow a distinct logical circuit
called a sub n to be run on inputs of
length n
okay so you imagine an infinite sequence
of circuits
one for each input length
okay so one for inverse of length 100
one for inputs of length ten thousand
and so on
and when i get an input of a certain
length you know imagine just feeding it
to
learn length and i feed it to a sub n it
gives me the answer okay in this way i
can talk about a circuit an infinite
circuit family computing an infinite
language
okay
and so the the notion of feasible
computation in this kind of
non-uniform model non-uniform in
contrast to the uniform where you have a
single algorithm that works on all
inputs no matter how long they are in
this non-uniform model feasibility
corresponds this class p poly which is a
class of problem solvable with a circuit
family infinite family of these circuits
a sub n
so that there exists a fixed polynomial
or you think of the constant k
so that for all n the size of the nth
circuit in terms of number of gates say
is at most into the k
all right
so um so i have
an infinite number of different programs
a different program run for each input
length
but for any fixed input length the
program is of size the most polynomial
in the input length okay so here i'm
studying how
the size of the computation scales with
the input
and i'm not saying here's a specific
algorithm that's going to run when
everything i'm really i really want to
study you know as input links grow what
does it
do to the relative size of computation
required okay
so in this model so here's just a few
important points in this model
programs have infinite length
descriptions
okay like just writing down the program
you have to write down one for each
input link and so you can get some funny
counter-intuitive results so for example
one problem which is
well-known to be undecidable is take the
the subset of one star where i put the
string of n1's if and only if the nth
string machine under some enumeration
halts on blank tape
okay this problem
is undecidable it's not too hard to see
why i mean
if you wrote the nth turning machine in
binary this is more or less follows from
rice's through something like that okay
but uh but you can
you know just reduce it to
this problem and so this problem is
undecidable nevertheless it is in pipali
okay
and the reason why is in p poly is that
for every input length
n there's two possibilities for the
function restricted in inputs it's
either all zeros it either accepts
nothing or it accepts the string of n
once
okay so so for example
if the first string machine halted on
blank tape my first circuit would just
be
you know take the and of all the
the inputs so well here it's just x1 so
i'll just
output one
like uh with m sub n if it halts
then i'll just take
the and of n1s
if it if it didn't halt on blank tape
then i could just
take instead the circuit
let's say x1 not x1 so this circuit
always outputs 0 no matter what input
you give it
so for every single input length i could
i will either put this circuit in there
or this circuit in there both were
polynomial size so the thing is in
pre-poly
okay
so
um i guess the main point about this is
that if you use a reduction
to prove undecidability and you spread
out the undecidability among
many many input links then in fact you
get feasibility here
and so the usual techniques and
computability theory
are
just more or less powerless for trying
to understand what is computable with
polynomial size circuits and what is not
okay
okay is there any questions about
nothing all right
right so so i want to talk about in
contrast to circuit analysis algorithms
which are which i was calling algorithms
for circuits
i'm going to talk about circuits for
algorithms okay this is a different kind
of problem this is a problem rooted in
circuit complexity
whereas the algorithm for circuits
problem is about circuit analysis
algorithms so again this is p poly
so
in the circuits for algorithms problem
we're trying to understand what kinds of
languages have small circuits in which
don't okay most boolean functions
require huge circuits i think russell
mentioned
this in his talk
for example if you just
randomly chose a function by just
picking a uniform random two to the n
bit string
this will require a circuit of size at
least to the n over n with high
probability
okay so most functions require you say
can we get our hands on
particular interesting functions that
require huge circuits
so the circuits for algorithms question
ask what uniform algorithms can be
simulated in p poly
okay so what problems
in the uniform world can be simulated in
p poly like for example p
polynomial time
can be simulated in p pi as we know
but it's
it's really hard to show that
uh
functions computable even sort of
weakly uniformly or not in p poly so
for example you could ask can huge
uniform classes like maybe p space
polynomial space or exponential time or
non-deterministic exponential time can
they be simulated with small
non-uniform classes like p poly okay
you would think
you know the answer to such a question
is just obviously no that like
allowing yourself exponential time
just because you spread you know you
allow a different circuit for each input
link
it it doesn't doesn't seem like that
would help you that like certain like
all of a sudden if i get to design a
separate computer for each input length
exponential time becomes polynomial
exponential is just too big
um
but we the thing is we just really don't
know how to reason about these infinite
models the key obstacle is that
non-uniformity can be very very powerful
and the best example of this i know is
is this very simple example that
undecidable problems can be in people
okay
so i mean
um
yeah so you're never gonna have for
example pea poly contained in any of
these things okay
uh just because it has undecidable
things in it
right
so so one big open problem
uh is whether nx is in p poly okay so
another way of saying this is can all
problems with exponentially long
solutions verifiable in exponential time
can they be solved with polynomial size
circuit families so if i
am allowed to lay out a separate circuit
for each input length and i could take
any amount of time i wanted to lay out
each circuit for engine input like it's
just does it exist or not
um
again
it seems here so you know np is
polynomial length solutions verifiable
polynomial time
here
even the solution that we want to find
uh is accidentally long the search space
is doubly exponentially
big
and yet we still can't rule out uh that
polynomial size circuits could just
solve the problem
okay
um so another way of thinking about this
is
just another perspective is given
infinite pre-processing time so
i so i put no bound on like how long it
might take you to find these
magical polynomial size circuits for
each input link
can you then construct a small
computation solving index problems
okay
so this is the kind of question that's
asked in circuit for algorithms these
kind of questions which seem seem
obviously to have no answers
but yet it's
it seems really hard to actually get a
handle on how you might prove that how
you might rule this kind of thing out
okay
so uh it's conjectured for example so we
don't know if nx was contained in be
poly non-deterministic exponential time
it's conjecture that np is not in b poly
this would be a strengthening of p
different from mp
okay so we don't expect it to be proved
uh
assuming even in x minus p poly
seems pretty hard at the moment
but in other words we think that the sat
problem cannot be
in p slash poly
um like it just seems that
if you wanted to solve like the sat
problem let's say on a instances of
length a million there's no there's not
going to be some efficient chip design
you know even
maybe hard to obtain but there's not
going to be any efficient chip design
logic design you could lay out and you
know somehow some some polynomial in a
million uh be able to solve sat with it
okay
so
proving things like np not in p poly
would be a first step to getting
concrete numerical trails between the
sizes of inputs in the computation
and the size of the computation
themselves
okay so like suppose you wanted to
prove that
you know within
the known universe we cannot construct
a computer
that will solve sat
on instances of length all instances of
length a million okay
so this you can think of np rnp poly is
an asymptotic version of this kind of
statement trying to prove that kind of
thing and indeed
in the past
uh meyer and stockmeyer used a very
strong
circuit lower bound for a problem
in exponential space
and
use it just a simple logic problem in
exponential space
and show that
any circuit that solved this problem on
instance of let's say
length at most 700 bits
okay it would require a computer
larger than 10 to the 80 okay gates okay
so
we can
sort of safely
assume that that we we're not going to
have a chip that will that will solve
this logic problem
okay
um so you can imagine
trying to prove this kind of thing for
problems we really care about integer
factorization
i mean if or maybe you know maybe if
there are small circuits for energy
factorization
but this is
one of the chief motivations for looking
at circuit complexity in this way okay
for looking at at p slash poly you could
prove between from mp and be nowhere
near proving a result
of of this kind i was saying like a
concrete numerical result that you can't
solve satin instances of length a
million in the known universe okay
would you but depending on how you prove
this you could potentially
uh have that as a corollary okay
okay
so
uh even though we think that
x is not np poly nx is not mp poly i
like to at least say that there
there were famous mathematicians that
thought perhaps the opposite was true
okay
so uh coma giroff
actually hypothesized that uh polynomial
time has linear size circuits okay you
can think of this as like a very scaled
down version of saying
you know x
exponential time has smaller than
exponential size circuits okay
so so in other words every problem in p
even if it took into the hundred time
into the million time to solve
he believed well perhaps there's a
linear size circuit family so for any
yes and it literally does imply that x
has two to the delta and surface
property yes it does by padding yes
yes
so it's even stronger than that
yeah
that's right so this would be remarkable
not only for the reason russell pointed
out but in fact a proof of penance np
would just follow immediately from from
proving this kind of circuit upper bound
you would get peter from mp
and um so the the main reason was more
or less sketched in in russell's talk
okay so
from russell's talk we can
say that there is a language
in uh
the third level of pulmonary hierarchy
sigma 3
p
such that
l
does not have circuits
of even
in squared size
okay
okay and this is
essentially by
guessing
a function which doesn't have such
circuits okay then universally verifying
using maybe another existential
quantifier to check that it actually
doesn't
guessing the lexicographically first
function
on let's say n cubed bits that doesn't
have n squared size circuits and then
verifying that our guess is correct okay
but just go by trying all possible
circuits in the universal quantifier
then checking it's the first one using
existential quantifier the other
exponential okay
but if
so this is just a fact and this
follows uh
from common
now if p hold in p
hm
if p equal to n p
then sigma 3
p would equal p
and so we would have a language in p
that doesn't have say n squared psi
circuits
okay
so if if p goes in p
then p does not have say n squared size
circuits definitely doesn't have linear
size
okay
all right
so um so this is a very intriguing thing
you might wonder why why on earth would
he conjecture this i mean he was a very
famous very smart mathematician surely
he had some reason
well he did
so oops
sorry my computer is like
being squishy
so um
so in the course of resolving
hilbert's thirteen problem with vi
arnold como golf showed the following he
showed that any n variable continuous
function
can be actually
written as an arithmetic circuit of a
certain kind
okay where the gates are just the
summation
of two things so it's like the one gauge
is just a sum a fan into let me just
write something in
so like one gate is just going to sum
its
two inputs and produce an output and
another one is just going to compute an
arbitrary
one variable continuous function okay so
just you know given an x outputs and f
of x given x and y
x plus y okay so they actually showed
that
any n variant continuous function
can be written
as let's say order n squared
as a circuit with order n squared gates
of this form okay so you have some
circuit
that's got
n inputs on it
okay and it's got these
sums and it's got these
you like one variate
uh continuous functions
and somehow it computes the whole
invariant continuous function
it's a very very
non-trivial very very interesting result
and so when he first heard of bullying
circumplexity he thought why not
um
yeah so i mean
well okay the the
the the gates of finn and two that we
have are and or
you know xor
but uh
yeah maybe that maybe there is something
to this
maybe not
um but anyway i just wanted to show that
there is like a counter intuition to to
all these circuit lower bounds
okay yeah
what did he do with his hypothesis so
could he prove anything assuming it was
true
uh
i don't think he did others did
later
yeah uh for example dick lipton has a
whole paper
about
if p has linear size circuits the
following interesting world happens
oh p it was for p
lipton's paper and cz 1994 is
on uh assuming p has linear size
circuits all these
over 67.
and there's been follow-up work so so we
kind of understand the world where this
habits is true but we don't know how to
show this world as contradictory at all
like
it's it seems totally self-consistent
and it's just
okay maybe it's
any more questions
okay so one thing i want to point out
and what i'm going to say here is
kind of recapping some of what russell
said but it's worth repeating is that
these questions have interesting
consequences no matter how you end up
resolving them maybe you end up showing
extra small circuits maybe you show they
don't either way you get
you get something interesting so as uh
russell mentioned if x is in p poly then
p is not equal np well maybe you said
the cons are positive
i just said that when x equals sigma two
it does follow the fusion from npc yeah
yeah well from
yeah yeah from that sort of thing okay
okay so okay so if x is in p poly then p
is there from mp and it follows roughly
the same kind of argument so
and in fact you can say the stronger
folklore theorem
in fact i don't know this folklore
theory may be due to valentine for
helena
it's okay valentine's folklore
so if every problem into the order end
time
has circuits smaller than say even 1.99
to the in size okay just you know just
some slight improvement over to the end
okay for amply many input links
then then p is in from mp okay and it
follows the same sort of of argument
because you can construct
functions
not in to the order end time
deterministically but if you add some
quantifiers you're working like sigma 3
to the order end time you can construct
circuits that do not have
so if you can't construct functions do
not have circuit smaller than this okay
and but then if p equal to np
um you know that it would contradict
the contradiction so
that would mean everything in sigma 3
to the order end time can be solved
deterministically into the order of time
in fact they point out it doesn't even
have to be 1.99 it could just be max
like it's something smaller than the
maximum one off by the maximum zero
complexity i guess right yeah okay
i wasn't sure who first proved it but
are you
are you really the
are you really the first person
i don't
know now that i have you here i mean
so okay on the other hand suppose uh so
okay maybe x doesn't have polynomial
size circuits then you get pseudo-random
generators okay
um so for example a theorem by russell
and avi says that if some problem into
the order end time needs circuits larger
than 1.99 in size for almost all input
links so i just basically wrote
the negation here very carefully then p
equals bbp
okay
so
either way you know upper bounds
or lower bounds you get you get some
extremely interesting results in
complexity theory okay
and in fact even proving uh nx is not mp
poly you can get some kind
of
elimination of randomness you can get
some kind of de-randomization but not
necessarily for
randomized computations by themselves
but for merlin arthur so this is
problems um that can be verified using
randomness okay so it's a it's like the
randomized version of np
where merlin gives some proof
it's like you make a guess and arthur
thoughts of some coins and then verifies
maryland's proof okay so you can
simulate maryland arthur non-trivially
non-deterministically okay so you can
remove the randomness at a cost of some
sub-exponential or anything and i i
guess you're going to talk about this
maybe
tomorrow or the next day
eventually right because easy witness
sort of uses this yeah yeah yeah yeah
okay so if you see his easy witness
talk
this will make more sense the point is
even improving this weak
weak looking
circuit lower bound already gets you
some non-trivial dear randomization okay
already says you can remove randomness
in some way okay
okay
any any questions about
these things um
theorem is infinitely many and
iw is almost all
yeah yeah so if you had infinitely many
here
then you would have bbp instantly often
np
okay but there is an analog
as well
yes yes yes exactly
yeah so if you had infinite many here
you would have be infinitely
for amply many input links ppp
computation can be simulated in p
yeah
but this circuit lower bound for like
sigma 3 to the order end time that holds
for for every input length for almost
every input link so this is why you can
say even implementing input links
implies p different mapping
anymore yeah
i'm playing both sides of the field here
but like uh
but most people believe
that um kind of the bottom two there
that uh these two yes yes
yes yes most people believe
that but
yeah
okay
okay so that's my uh
30 minute brief summary of uh
circuit complexity uh yes
yes yes yes so here the infinity minute
almost all are important right otherwise
you'd get people dvd sometimes when you
get what sorry so if you improve the
statements prefer all input lengths
through this statement for all input
links
no that would be weaker
so if every problem is circuit smaller
than that for all input links that would
also imply this because that's a
stronger hypothesis
then you get p with pvp
as stated
if you get it for infinitely many input
links then b b then
so carefully you know yeah set it up so
that these are like absolutely negations
each other but i encourage you to yeah
keep thinking about it
okay
any more questions
do you have a question also
do you have a okay
you're just wondering
like is there any hope of saying like
trying to accounting argument to say
there's just too many functions in in
exp for to be solved by polynomial side
circuits
oh could you possibly use a counting
argument
well
the thing is the number of languages in
x
you know is sort of you know it's kind
of it's recursive like you can list them
all there's a non-deterministic
existential time machine
you know sort of corresponding to each
one of them
um
i'm not sure yeah what accounting
argument would look like but
i mean it's is it are you saying like
maybe you could
somehow yeah i don't i don't know like
how you would use the structure of nx in
accounting argument but it's a
why not i mean try it
oh uh
okay i chose 1.99 so that this statement
would be true
so so in order for them to reach their
conclusion they would like to have two
to the delta n for some delta less than
one
so yeah 0.99 is arbitrary there yeah
yeah this is the sort of
yes arbitrary constant
that i
sort of put close to two
but greater than one less than two yeah
yeah putting the number so that they
match but you could
increase the number on the first one and
decrease the number on the second one
yeah it is still true that's true yeah
you could decrease the number on this
one and increase the number on this one
and these implications still hold
but they no longer look as nice because
they're no longer exact negative to each
other that's all
yeah
okay
good
okay
so
uh so that's what i wanted to say at
least to
uh refresh uh
your memory or
introduce you to solid complexity now i
want to to speak a bit about connections
okay
so we have these two
areas that we've been talking about one
is algorithms for circuits or the
circuit analysis algorithms or it's
something called meta algorithms
so this is just the task of designing
faster circuit analysis you give me some
circuit or you give me some boolean
function tell me something about the
zerg complexity okay i mean even sat can
be seen as something like tell me
something about the circumplexity is it
a trivial function or not does it have
non-trivial circumplexity sat can be
seen in this way as well
okay
so the circuit for algorithms problem or
circuit complexity as i have
it here is
we would like to design small circuits
to simulate complicated algorithms like
exponential time algorithms or
non-internalizational time items are
prove that small circuits don't exist in
some form or another
so can we use one of these tasks to
inform the other
um
so the most intriguing
sort of connection would be things like
can we use our design here like sort of
faster set algorithms faster cap
algorithms stuff like that to tell us
something about the limitations of
circuits okay
so to me this is
sort of the more interesting direction
because the conventional wisdom is that
album design is something
and we can wrap our heads around really
very easy but thinking about all
possible circuits and what everything
they could possibly do seems hard okay i
mean there are connections in the
opposite direction as
russell's lectures will tell you a lot
about i'll talk a bit about them too
but i i really like these connections
because it's sort of like the best kind
of computer science arbitrage
opportunity
like we have lots and lots of algorithm
design techniques we have very few lower
bounds so you know if you can really
you know take things here and push them
there then you know maybe you could
you know dip the balancing
a bit more okay get more lower bounce
okay all right so
um just to get started
so this theorem of carplifter and meier
that russell mentioned can be seen in
the following light
suppose we had extremely efficient
circuit analysis algorithms
okay suppose p equals np so we can solve
things like
circuit sat in polynomial time we can
solve circuit minimization and
polynomial time great
okay
so then we could prove that there are
problems solvable into the end time that
are not in p slash poly okay in other
words if p equals np
you have sort of perfect circuit
analysis algorithms
then you can find functions in
exponential time it can't be in p poly
it don't have an infinite family of poly
size circuits
right
so
this is just you know another way of of
restating the thing and just trying to
fit it into this
question of circuit analysis versus
circuit lower balance okay now this is a
very interesting conditional statement
but of course like
it's a limited utility if you actually
want to prove circuit lower bounds
because we don't believe the hypothesis
okay
so
one uh
big goal in this area is to find
hypotheses much much weaker than p
equals np
for which you can still conclude circuit
lower bounds from those hypotheses okay
and we'll see several examples of that
so another uh
place where circuit analysis algorithms
inform circuit limitations is in this
minimum circuit science problem studied
by valentine genius psy so they studied
many consequences of this thing just to
remind you
mcsp
in this problem we're given the truth
table of a boolean function so we're
given 2 to the n bits okay just the
entire
table of the function and the parameter
s we want to know if that function is a
circuit of size and most s
okay so you know given this function
just laid out completely for you is
there like is there a way to compress
the representation of this function
to something at most s okay there's
another way of thinking about it
okay so they show that if this problem
were in polynomial time you would get
quite a few interesting consequences for
one um this class exponential time with
an np oracle so i haven't
said anything about it yet but let me at
least you know
uh
in the spirit of russell draw some
diagrams or something
um
so
there's all these different classes
flying around so i feel obligated to
just draw some little kind of picture
here so
x to the np
and x is contained in that
x containing that
p space
okay
we have uh
uh like sigma
kp's
okay
and we have sigma two p
everything's like merlin arthur
okay
all right
uh okay so x to the np
would was slightly bigger than in x it's
like you get to ask exponentially long
queries to an emp oracle okay so you get
to sort of
solve in x problems some exponential
number of times okay this class will
require maximum circuit complexity
now
as far as i know the best
upper bound for a function of maximum
circumplexity
it's not even
it's not even like sigma 2x it's more
like
sigma 3x but i'd be happy if i
if somebody could
is that there i don't know of like
the construction of a function like uh
like smaller than sigma 3x that requires
maximum circumplexity so in the spirit
of russell like if mcsp
is in p then the shell falls down and
and you get a function here actually mp
at least for that particular language
not the whole shelf just a heavy heavy
book on the shelf not the whole shelf
because the heavy book falls to xcmp and
so
there's some language here which can be
implemented here which has maximum
circumplace you know by maximum i mean
like
essentially to the n over n exactly
whatever the hardest
whatever like that number is for the
hardest uh the largest circuit size of
an embed boolean function
there's a language and xcmp is going to
have a particular language is going to
have it for every input link okay
so this would be new circuit lower
balance
you would also get a collapse of two
different kinds of randomized
computation so zbp is zero error
randomized computation just recall and
bb is the two-sided version
essentially like this is a also called
the las vegas class of algorithms where
you never
uh make a mistake you just output don't
know
in some cases and here you could you
could err in the yes case and then okay
and these two things would collapse
if you had a polite time algorithm like
this
okay
and uh
and as i briefly mentioned last time a
lot of different problems for which
cryptography is based on like discrete
log factoring and even graphite some
more of them they would all be in bbp if
mcsp or even in randomized polymer time
that would be true okay
but also you would have something very
unlikely okay you would have there are
no strong pseudo-atom functions they're
strong very strong pseudo-atom
generators
okay
and i'll say a little bit more about
that
later okay
so
we can also think of the the natural
proof barrier of raspberry from rudige
as being a connection of this kind where
certain analysis algorithms imply
something about limitations of circuits
okay
so just to say at a very high level what
i mean suppose while proving a circuit
lower bound okay in the course of doing
it
you not only prove that some function
doesn't have small circuits you actually
construct a polynomial time algorithm
okay this final time algorithm can take
it takes truth tables a function as
input okay it can do sort of two key
things it can distinguish many functions
so random functions say they're not
computable with these circuits whatever
circle around you're proving you can see
which many functions not computable from
all the easy functions are computable
with the circuits okay
so not only did you prove that a
particular function doesn't have
some small circuits you developed an
algorithm that took takes arbitrary
truth tables it can say for many many
functions it will say yes these aren't
computable for all the easy functions
that are computer it will say no okay so
we can do this very nice distinguishing
thing okay
okay if you can do that if you do that
in your circuit lower bound
so the way you're thinking about this is
that
mcsp is kind of in p what this is sort
of saying so mcsp is saying give me a
true table what's the circuit complexity
here i want to apolo time algorithm
given the truth table will say on many
functions the right answer it'll say yes
these don't have small circuits and for
all the easy functions that are people
it will say the right answer okay so
this sort of
you can think of this as mcsp is kind of
np
okay if you can do that then
those circuits whatever you prove to
circuit lower bound against they're too
weak to support pseudorandom functions
okay
so this is you can easily think of this
as a circuit analysis algorithm
you know on the apollo time algorithm
manipulating
uh truth tables in these circuits that
shows that these circuits are too weak
to do something okay but the punch line
here
is not that we get you know a circuit
lower bound because we believe
pseudorandom functions exist
so we think that the problem time
algorithms should not exist
so we sort of draw a different moral
from this kind of connection okay
so
uh we believe that in fact very low
depth circuits like say out of majority
gates can support pseudorandom functions
and so there shouldn't be palm time
algorithms that can distinguish many
functions computable with those circuits
from all the easy ones
okay in other words if we believe it's
possible to prove lower bounds we're
strong enough to support cryptography
then we should also believe that these
natural proofs so
net proofs which construct these time
algorithms are not
going to be able to prove things like
peter and memphi
okay
so but unfortunately most
arguments for strong circular balance
actually do have a polynomial time
algorithm embedded in them or they can
be extracted from the proof in some way
or another
so that's sort of the remarkable
uh thing about the natural boost
barrier is that
uh circuit many circuit lower bounds
actually are proved in this way
maybe implicitly in some cases
in in which case they're just too weak
to prove strong enough lower bounds
okay
it's possible to prove um bound which is
strong enough to support crypto yeah
like in other words
yeah things like yeah
strong enough to like create
cryptographic prg
if we believe in the if we believe like
lower bounds like we would believe that
cryptography is possible in a certain
sense okay then there must be certain
lower bounds
okay
and then natural proofs will not be able
to
just to give you even you know weaker
lower bounds
because they would rule out the
cryptography in the process
is it
does that make sense
yeah so the the usual way i mean just to
match this up with maybe the way you've
you may have seen the natural proof
spirit before if you have
is that it would be nice if i could draw
on my computer but uh i'm not going to
draw
so whatever
just just for the moment okay
don't get
i guess the people at home are just
gonna miss out so like
okay so the poly time algorithm is often
called
constructive
being constructive
and distinguishing many functions not
computable this is often called the
largeness property
and from all these functions that are
computable this is being useful okay the
whole purpose of a lower bound is to
show that all the easy functions can be
computed
some way or another by your function
okay so usually the way you look at the
what is it actually
okay sorry so um
so so the usual way you would say these
things in
natural proof terminology is that
you have some property of boolean
functions that's constructive you have a
political algorithm it's large it's many
functions and useful okay
all right
all right
just to match it up
with your intuition if you've seen these
things before
okay
all right so i did want to say a bit
about
arithmetic complexity
um
i don't know to what extent russell's
going to speak about but it should
certainly be mentioned one way or
another
on friday
okay so this is like a warm up to
russell's talk okay sort of like a
pre-prep so
so uh this deals with a different model
okay it's not the usual
circuit model of an ors and knots
we deal with arithmetic formulae so so
our operations are like plus and times
let's say it was an integers
instead of or ant okay
and so the the rough analog of the sat
problem
in arithmetic formulae is polymer
identity testing so given two arithmetic
formulas f and g do they represent the
same polynomial okay and by that i mean
literally their coefficients match up
exactly in every single term
okay
so it's just checking so they might be
written in different ways right you can
write
polynomials in all kinds of different
ways you just want to know you know if
it's written in way f and way g are they
actually the same polynomial if you
expanded the whole thing out and looked
at the sum of products
so here's some examples
uh
like euler made a living off these kind
of things
so you know
uh well this one's easy maybe this one
okay
that's easy so like this is a f and a g
and
you can sort of concoct all sorts of
left-hand sides and your right-hand
sides which
you know happen to match up in all the
coefficients but knowing when this is
the case when it's not
you know it seems it could be difficult
to do
okay but there are efficient randomized
algorithms for polynomial identity
testing
okay and the the main idea behind those
is you just pick sufficiently large
random values you plug in for all the
variables on both sides okay just
efficiently large random values so
switching a large set
just plug them all in and just check if
when you simplify it when you when you
simplify the left-hand side right do
they are they equal or not
this turns out to be extremely effective
randomized algorithm but no efficient
deterministic algorithms or no there's
no way just sort of concoct
uh you know a really small nice set of
points you could just plug in no matter
what and get it to work okay
or just maybe doing something totally
different like
doing some interesting interpolation on
both left and right hand side
somehow
okay
so it's a big big open problem to find
you know even sub-exponential
determinants time determines the
government for this
okay
so
a really really influential
theorem of valentine and russell from
2004
is a connection between
circuit analysis algorithms for
polynomial dna testing in this case for
arithmetic formulas and formula lower
bounds so they show that sub exponential
time algorithms for problem identity
testing
on formulas will get you formula size
lower balance on circuits you can get
circuit lower bounds there is a nice
correspondence between these things so
somehow understanding
polynomials as formulas say well enough
to know when two of them are the same
gives you enough leverage to actually
prove a limitation on what they can
express as polynomials okay
so more formally they show that either
in x is not mp poly or the permanent
does not have arithmetic formulas of
polynomial size this this result has
since been sharpened the consequence so
what can you just
uh tell me what the new consonant is
like just recently very recently the
consequence um
so
um
maybe mark okay multi-linear interpol
the multi-linear interpolation of
so if i write something
like this
uh
yeah like some twiddle there's a thing
this is like some twiddle
of this does not have algebraic
polymorph side circuits that is a
consequence
of
efficient
okay
something like
an x-intercept coenex
so it's so it's sort of been improved
the consequence of it
okay let's say this
oh even even sub exponential do you sub
essentials enough to get your
consequences too yeah so like 2 to the
n to the little of one where n is the
size of the expression so to the end of
the low of one or two to the end the
epsilon for every epsilon i think i
don't think you need something
computable
you do oh you do but you didn't hear
right
okay
all right
all the time yeah
yeah
yeah something something good something
much much better than what we know
much better than two to the n or
whatever okay so
efficient algorithms for analyzing
arithmetic formulas imply limitations on
representing explicit polynomials with
small formulas okay again the same uh
kind of lesson that we were talking
about with these things like if p equals
np then you get circuit lower bounds
okay
question about the statement the thing
russell will talk about more detail
later
and this is just a branch of what
russell was talking about earlier about
de-randomization and applying lower
bounds
uh yeah yeah yeah because this is a
guess because this is a problem solvable
efficiently with randomness yeah this is
sort of a special problem you're
analyzing this problem this is a problem
centric yes
yeah yeah
yeah so
yeah everything is about arithmetic
yeah
you can you can phrase it in terms of
circuits i like formulae because i can
sort of write them on the slide easy
that was that was essentially like oily
looked at formulae so you know that was
it those are you can you can say
everything in terms of circuits
okay
so uh
there's a
connection that's been recently
developed
um and you can actually just sort of
still ongoing where in the boolean
setting
you can show that slightly faster albums
for c-sets again recall that like c-set
was you could in this place of c you
could put c and f you could put formulas
you could put circuits
arbitrary circuits
um so in general you can show that
slightly faster albums than exhaustive
search for csat
imply lower bounds against that class of
circuits see okay so just in pictures
suppose you know this is an example
circuit from my class c
suppose
inspecting this circuit i can find an
assignment which makes the circuit print
one or conclude there's no such
assignment and i can do this not in
2 to the n times n of the c time should
be the naive thing
but i can do it in let's say to the n
over n to the 10 time okay
and let's say i can do this for all
constants
see no matter what the
constant little c is here and the size
maybe the you know there's some
dependence in the big o on the c i can
get to the n over instant
okay so this is a very very minor
improvement over exhaustive search
nothing like 1.9 of the n
nothing like even to the n minus into
the epsilon
this is to the n over a polynomial a
fixed polynomial
again this 10 is just chosen to be
sufficiently large you could make it
maybe four or three depending it
actually begins to depend on the
computational model you're looking at
if you you bring this constant down
far enough
so if you can do that if you can solve
circuit set even slightly faster than
exhaustive search like that then for the
same class of circuits you can conclude
there is a function
in non-intermediate exponential time
that does not have poly size circuits
okay so if this were a c circuit class
then this would be n x does not have
poly size c circuits here
okay but if the arbitrary circularized
if you're solving circuit set
uh on arbitrary circuits you get an x
input poly
okay
uh and so this
looks really nice i mean
i mean for one people had not really
looked at getting this kind of minor
improvement over exhaustive search
before mainly uh people will just focus
on you know if you have a c to thin
algorithm i would like something like c
minus epsilon to the n you know like a
1.9 to the n time algorithm but this is
showing that like you know even tiny
improvements will get you
already some
some significant lower bounce okay
there's those circuits
yeah maybe this you know makes sense
just because nx is such a big class you
know
maybe you don't have to understand
circuits so well to to separate in
excellent people i just understand them
well enough to get something slightly
faster into you okay
so this is a fairly
broad kind of theorem
in the sense that if you have say a
faster circuit set algorithm you get an
x100 mp poly
if you have formula sat
fast around for formula set
you get
lower bounce for formulas
uh in in other words nx is not a
non-uniform in c1 basically nx does not
have
an infinite sequence of polynomial size
formulas
that work for you know every input
length okay
and for this class acc we talked about
last time solving it faster than to the
end
actually imply nx not in acc okay we we
showed uh at least briefly outlined how
you could
get such an algorithm last time
okay so we get a lower bound for this
acc thing
but um another thing that's important to
to mention
and uh could be very useful in the hunt
for lower balance proofs is that you
don't have to solve the sat problem okay
you don't have to you don't have to
solve like the full set problem you
actually just have to de-randomize the
problem we think is in polynomial time
okay so the the problem is the following
given a circuit c that's either
completely unsatisfiable
or at least half its assignments are
satisfied okay but you don't know which
ones you know you just you just promise
that it's either totally unsatisfiable
or has assignments are satisfying you
just want to know which is the case
and you don't get to use randomness
you you have to somehow
deterministically
figure out which of these two is the
case
again into the n over and thin time
okay now again this because we believe
uh bvp is equal to p
we believe this problem is solvable in
polynomial time deterministically we
just want to beat that okay we just want
to be the exhaustive search okay
again you would get an x is not mp poly
and set and since uh the original paper
it's been
shown i can work with rahul santana that
this kind of connection between
circuits you know just distinguishing
between unsat
and
sat almost everywhere
getting lower bounce this connection
also holds even for really low circuit
classes
like
tc0 so constant depth majority gates
like having some algorithm which
solves this very very basic
de-randomization problem
will get you lower balance against tc0
circuits
okay
can you also get size improvements
so if you had a good algorithm for
nearly exponential size structures can
you get that nxt is not inside this
potential
um so you so there you can get there is
a tradeoff up to some point
um
but getting like truly exponential lower
bounds is going to be hard because
there's this easy witness lima thing
that goes on in this proof which is
going to reduce the size of the lower
bound you're going to get
but if you go up to
x to the mp from nx then you can you can
start to prove things like that given a
set algorithm for exponential sized
circuits you can get exponential size
lower balancers
oops
wait what what is going on
yeah i have like a phantom
clicker what is going on
right
this thing's been
ghosting the machines
wait so where was i okay there
this looks like a good place to stop
actually uh okay um
i think there's like a hair on my track
pad
i think that's all
there's a hair on my trackpad
and
did you just go over them while the
ghost is running
uh wow okay
this is let's see is there any way to
stop
i can just keep holding this down or
something
hmm
okay it kind of stopped
no it didn't stop
so okay there are many well-known
connections between
so uh russell's gonna cover this
uh
for a restricted circuit sometimes for
the techniques used you're going too
fast man
what's what's going on
you're going too fast you're going you
got to slow down
you got to slow down maybe i should
restart the powerpoint
time
i think i'm almost done yeah i think
it's a good time to stop
um so how about i conclude yeah
since we didn't have a chairman the
machine actually took over yeah he was
like you know what finish your talk
finish your talk now yeah yeah automatic
chair yeah
yeah so what you wanted to say before
the
crash i i don't remember
uh
what was i saying you know
no but what what will they missing slice
oh no no you're going to see them next
time no no
like this is a two lecture lecture
yeah
here i will just pick up from there next
time you're not going to miss a thing
yeah yeah so this is circuit complexion
connections one
tomorrow you'll get certain complexity
connections too
yeah no worries you won't miss a thing
yay i know you think the other direction
you mentioned that the other direction
is less interesting but in the setting
of set algorithms
um
what what do we have from generic lower
bounds by direction you mean instead of
like using
instead of using lower bound proofs to
get these algorithms which we know we
can do yeah if you just assume
a lower bound and kind of a black box
i mean i wasn't trying to diss you know
people who work in the opposite
direction uh
so
it's a very interesting question whether
circuit lower bounds could imply circuit
set algorithms
um
yeah that that seems
that seems uh
like a really interesting question it
may not be possible
to prove it for all i know um in a black
box way so it's known that like right if
you open up the proofs the circular
bounds you look at random restriction
method you look at shrinkage stuff like
this yes you can get algorithms out of
that there's entire papers written on
this which i was quoting like as my
slides were flying through but okay
but um
yeah i think this is a very interesting
question so from sat algorithms we know
how to get lower bounce going the
opposite direction even like even if you
need like lots of technical conditions
to make that direction work would still
be very very interesting
absolutely
more questions
let's thank ryan again